donald trump qui durcit le ton avec
pékin ils menacent de mettre fin aux
exemptions accordées à hong kong dans le
cadre de sa relation spéciale avec les
états unis à l'origine de ce regain de
tensions entre les deux puissances le
vote il ya deux jours par le parlement
chinois d'une loi qui selon ses
détracteurs visent à réduire les
libertés dans l'ex colonie britannique
aux actuels le ton monte entre pékin et
la communauté internationale malgré les
mises en garde de la part des etats-unis
du royaume-uni du canada et de
l'australie
le parlement chinois a approuvé jeudi le
projet de loi qui ouvre la possibilité à
pékin de réprimer sur le territoire hong
kong et toute activité susceptible de
menacer la sécurité nationale
face à cette avancée les états unis et
le royaume uni ont convoqué une réunion
informelle du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu ce vendredi à huis clos et par
visioconférence une manoeuvre très peu
appréciée par la chine
pékin accuse les etats-unis de prendre
en otage l'organe des nations unies et
déplore le soutien affiché par mike
pompéo aux manifestants à hong kong
la question de la législation sur la
sécurité nationale ne relèvent tout
simplement pas des responsabilités du
conseil de sécurité
la non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures est un principe important de
la charte des nations unies
l'appel des états unis à une discussion
sur les questions liées à hong kong au
sein du conseil de sécurité interfèrent
ouvertement dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine et sa
délibérément les normes des relations
internationales le conseil de sécurité
n'est pas un outil que les états unis
peuvent utiliser à volonté
la chine et d'autres pays défendra la
justice ne permettront pas aux états
unis de détourner le conseil de sécurité
à ses propres fins en réponse au vote du
parlement chinois
donald trump a confirmé les menaces de
washington le président américain a
décidé de révoquer les privilèges
accordés à hong kong et dont bénéficient
la chine
je demande à mon administration de
commencer le processus de révocation des
exemptions qui offre à hong kong un
traitement différent est spécial
cette décision concerne la totalité des
accords que nous avons avec
kong des traités d'extradition du
contrôle des exportations et des
technologies à quelques exceptions près
nous allons réviser le guide du
département d'état pour les voyages à
hong kong pour refléter les risques de
l'accroissement de la surveillance et
des sanctions avec la nouvelle loi de
sécurité du gouvernement chinois
l'europe reste de son côté plus mesuré
précisons que les sanctions ne sont pas
la solution mais bruxelles met en garde
la chine face à cette décision
nous voulons également souligné que nos
relations avec la chine sont fondées sur
le respect mutuel et la confiance je
tiens à souligner cela le respect mutuel
et la confiance
cette décision remet ça en question et
je pense que nous devrons soulevé cette
question dans le cadre de la poursuite
de notre dialogue avec la chine
malgré l'opposition de la communauté
internationale
pékin accélère le processus législatif
le comité permanent de l'assemblée
nationale populaire devrait rédiger un
texte de loi au cours du mois de juin
qui pourraient être intégrées dans la
mini constitution de hong kong dès la
fin du mois d'août